welcome to this video against his like
Marta from Turkey yes play good score
against the sky plus three at least
check ok again practicing this line
trying to remember my own book always
funny you know what's funny i had
exactly the same line in the game before
that i didn't upload the game I want it
but he disconnected after like 10 or 12
moves or so the guy not this kind of
rage quit or whatever it was just just a
technical issue and I thought it wasn't
worth uploading such a quick game yeah
h5 is normally played here or quincy to
those kind of moves
yeah that's very very sharp stuff I play
95 here or not I think I do yeah no
white place cd5 normally yeah this you
can also play check
now very very double-edged position
Black has the two bishops but at the
moment they're c8 Bishop it's not doing
that much White has the H file open nice
but what is he doing with it it's not
it's a very very unbalanced sharp
position Wow whether that looks good for
that so it's okay for me right he just
develops my queen yeah that's that's
kind of nice Knight takes Queen g2 and
24 that's an endgame that should be
quite okay for black Bishop air is nice
but okay I'm not the bishop on CA it is
not doing much yeah so how do i play
this interesting interesting question
actually if I want to take on d4 or not
developing him
let's do this here it's a week poem but
at the same time a bishop is getting
getting activated tough decision but I
think it's okay so it's not even taking
em right tries to keep things on the
board Queen age 60 s a route we have
seven nights not that's not such a big
deal I wonder if I go b6 b6 Bishop a 6
you will probably castle but how to how
to play yeah this is some line from my
book repertoire very sharp line in fact
I think this is probably one of the best
lines against Knight bd21 move for a
terrific it requires some some knowledge
and some good nerves to play sometimes
but when this is for example this is
probably quite okay for black but it
kind of double edged it's not not easy
okay Bishop h6 a queen age 6 rook f7 I
don't see how he really continues you
have is hanging and night before i take
'if five and in general this queen is
nice on d5 I'm controlling c4 he doesn't
have anything our damn bishops on c1
look and a one but I'm threatening
Bishop a six quite quite clearly
so he's allowing night xe5 what is the
line that you're thinking about what
should I just play Bishop a six and ask
him what his next move is maybe Bishop
t2 and castles long on but I mean or can
really just take this right what is
there what is the big point takes Queen
takes now I will take it come on I don't
see it it's it's it's not just the pawn
that is going away it's also the piece
that controls or PM it is the pawn that
controls f6d six and kind of yeah helps
to cramp my king position so I'm glad to
get rid of this porn
okay so we just trade trade down here or
yeah I wonder if I should trade
everything okay h7 hangs that's not good
yeah I mean okay i can just take Windex
g5 but this is not not at all easy to
win this end game and if i take i can
take here check let's do that and now
maybe just aged five years or is there
some some nicer way to cover h7 don't
see it okay it's not so that it's kind
of awkward
checking the night 94 maybe 94 I thought
would be 50 what ok now I'm going to
take that check and what now aged 49 th
for ya if i take that is going to play
work 28 that's awkward so we'll let
think for a moment here there should be
seven or just Bishop e7 yeah be should
be seven days ok and now maybeee 54
Bishop f5 check yeah that's good getting
this out with temple yeah I take it and
take it rook h1 I have king king f7 and
sorry king of seven Jack what am I doing
here actually here yes yes Ruby why
morning Oh what am I doing here I
already screwing this up that that would
be really really bad King king I can't
believe it kinky aid rookie one yet I
really have screwed it up amazing oh
okay check yeah very embarrassing so you
him draw offered massless I still think
I'm better here actually with the f porn
check but maybe I'm too optimistic the f
bonus is very strong check check check
check mate wow yeah unbelievable stuff
it really really completely screwed that
one up from here i am jim can play
probably about anything but somehow not
not what i did i mean i'm ok i'll check
here but but here i mean what did i do
kinky have suphan I can play here for
example and then then it's just over
yeah I'm getting this born and book
promote but somehow I didn't hit it went
yeah yeah yeah and this I mean I don't
know maybe I'm too optimistic but I
thought that really I could decline this
draw offer because of the f pawn yeah I
comp actually agrees yeah I'm better if
point is too strong let us check the
opening I want to look at the oak a
moment
because I tend to forget my own analysis
I think that this is not really that
great actually to take on just six check
see if five is better and here I'm
definitely okay i mean this is this is
out of the question here like has the
bishop and this sun is fine zero point
six and eight now is the engines
evaluation it wants to take be six sets
already cleared genetics I can take the
pawn yeah yeah here also can play Queen
to d5 but this is a cold-blooded move
really check this is this is totally ok
it keeps the pawn in an endgame so
nothing really to worry about ok this is
not bad he filed a strong guy up just
Bishop f5 this this is a simple move
that I did not consider hmm that's just
better simpler to play I mean this this
was of course just helping me but in any
case here here that was my idea that
that ok that would have been ok but II
five Bishop f5 was even was even better
okay thanks for watching